apostle is a 2018 Netflix original
horror movie set on the island of
Ariston the movie follows Thomas
Richardson as he attempts to rescue his
sister from a mysterious cult there's a
lot to unpack from the film and
throughout this video I'll be discussing
the movie in full detail there will be
heavy spoilers so it may be worth
skipping this for now if you want to go
into the film with fresh eyes with that
out the way I'm definition and I ruin
the movie so you don't have to buy
Apostles ending Thomas Richardson has
been through a lot after infiltrating
the mysterious call that inhabits the
island he discovers that they worship a
deity known as her we discovered that
the Islanders only kidnapped Thomas's
sister so that they could get the ransom
money in exchange for her life as the
crops on the island are beginning to
fail Malcolm who is the cult leader
discovers that under her the crops have
been failing and tries to feed her blood
he is also angered by the fact that her
shows herself to Thomas even though she
was meant to be for his eyes only it's
revealed that Malcolm and father Quinn
were in fact the ones who found her and
after witnessing what she could do
decided to exploit her abilities on the
island they have kept her prisoner and
fed her blood in order to make the crops
thrive quinn boasts at the film's end
that her was a machine not a god and
that he has been using her purely for
selfish reasons he goes on a rampage and
turns against everyone even attempting
to feed thomas to her in order to make
the island thrive once more this is
because her needed flesh and not just
blood Malcolm had been trying to abstain
from feeding her human flesh but in
doing so had forced the island to starve
as it is not nutritious enough for the
crops to grow from blood this surprises
everyone however by going over to Thomas
and saying free me my child
Thomas burns her and this fire quickly
spreads to the rest of the community
Thomas managed to escort his sister and
another Islander but is stabbed during
the escape by Quinn and lays down to die
Malcolm joins him as they watched the
survivors flee and we are hit with the
realization that Thomas's blood is
nourishing the crops and causing them to
grow
he has replaced her to me this piece
works as a metaphor for how the human
race is affecting the planet her axes of
metaphor for Mother Nature in the way
that if we feed and water her she grows
however if we look at it with the
mentality that Quinn had where the
planet is a machine then we are doomed
to do damage climate change is a huge
issue and mistreatment of the earth is
slowly causing it to decay and die we
must take on the responsibility
ourselves much in the same way that
Thomas did at the film's close if we
wish for it to survive for the next
generation it's a really
thought-provoking ending and I
definitely enjoyed the film more than
most Netflix original horror movies this
one has a lot of depth to it and the
metaphor definitely stands strong in my
opinion so what did you think of apostle
do you agree with my thoughts on the
film or do you have an alternative
theory comment below and let me know
this is a channel for people who are mad
about movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe make sure
you check out my recent breakdown of the
ending of bad times at the El Royale
label at the end of this video thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]